- I switched bitches like dirty drawers.
If this bitch don't do nothing
in like two hours and I'ma change bitches.
You feel me?
- [Mark] ATM, ATM.
Where were you? Where'd you grow up?
What neighborhood you're from?
- Los Angeles, California, South Central.
- [Mark] South Central.
And tell me about your childhood.
You grew up with both your parents?
- Actually no.
I grew up with my mom though, you know.
My mom was always around
and my uncles, as well
as my great-grandfather,
he was a factor too.
- [Mark] He was a what?
- He was a factor as far as my family.
- [Mark] Got it.
And how was your childhood?
- It was, childhood was rough.You feel me?
I grew up without my dad around
so my uncles always play father.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Mark] Right.
So, and they had a
whole bunch of going on.
So, you know what I'm saying?
My mom was a tough cookie too.
So, you feel me?
My mom was trying to be just
like her brothers and shit.
So it was just, it was
always rough coming up.
You know, my childhood was always rough.
- [Mark] Yeah. Any abuse
or anything like that.
- My mom used to my mom used
to bring these, you know,
these random guys in who
she liked, things like that.
You know, from different neighborhoods
of Los Angeles, California.
You know what I'm saying?
Some was drug heads and things like that.
So they used to put their hands on my mom.
You know what I'm saying?
This one guy broke my mom jaw.
So you know what I'm saying?
As a child coming up I was always helping
my mom fight these niggas off.
You feel me?
So that's why.
I had to be a man fast at a young age.
So, you feel me?
That's what led up to here, right now.
- [Mark] Yeah. What age were
you when you went on your own?
- When I left?
- [Mark] When you kind of moved out.
- I got kicked out the house when I was 14
'cause I got caught with two guns,
two forties, the same kind.
You feel me?
So my mom felt like I was
selling guns or some shit.
You feel me?
So she kicked me out the house at 14
but before then I was out, I
put a lot on my mom though.
So, you know what I'm saying?
I don't blame her. Yeah.
- [Mark] What did you do
for money at that point?
- What did I do for money?
I started stealing.
I started stealing cell phones,
but I always had it in the back of my mind
like my uncles is pimps.
You feel me?
My mom was trying to do that shit.
So that's what I always wanted to be.
You know what I'm saying?
I always wanted to be a
dope dealer and a pimp.
You know what I'm saying?
That was like, the things I wanted to do.
My uncles was always coming
in with different bitches.
You know what I'm saying?
All this jewelry and,
you know what I'm saying?
All of this, everything,
all of these cars.
And so I felt like that's
what I wanted to do,
but I didn't know how yet.
So I started stealing cell phones
and selling the cell phones to people.
You know what I'm saying?
And then I started selling dope.
You feel me?
And then I landed me my first bitch.
You know what I'm saying?
So after I got my first
bitch, it was over.
I took off from there. You feel me?
- [Mark] What age was that?
- I was 15. This was like the next year.
You feel me?
I was only in the streets like 12 months,
not even 12 months, 10
months. I'm like that.
Before I started, before I got cracking.
You feel me?
Like period.
- [Mark] And how many
girls do you have today?
- Right now I got 50 toes.
- [Mark] And what kind
of girls do you have?
Are all African American
or white, Hispanic?
- I got a Asian right now.
I got three black girls.
I got an Asian, three black girls,
and I got the white girl.
- [Mark] And so the
arrangement is they go out,
they make money and they give you?
- Everything.
- [Mark] Everything?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And what do they get in exchange?
- Well, the fact of the matter is
when you're dealing with prostitutes,
they don't know what
to do with their money.
You feel me?
So what they want is
protection, with them.
They want somebody to
be able to protect them
just in case they get into
something in these streets.
You feel me?
As well as they need
somebody that know what
to do with the money.
So if a female come across
a guy that's capable
of protection, as well as,
they know what they know how
to manage the money.
You know what I'm saying?
For example, they got
other hustles besides that.
You feel me.
So they don't depend on pimping.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's like, yeah, if he
sells dope, he sell weed.
He does this, he does that.
You feel what I'm saying?
It's like yeah, they can fuck with you.
So that's really what it's about.
So yeah, they give me all the money.
You know what I'm saying?
And I know what to do with the money.
I go flip some packs or whatever.
You feel me?
I get us an apartment, a
place to stay, vehicles.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, everything we need.
- [Mark] Are they addicted to drugs?
- Some are, some are.
The majority of them are.
I try and stay away from the drug heads
because it's a lot of problems.
You feel me?
In situations and I'm human.
So it's like...
- [Mark] Do you supply
them with the drugs?
- Yeah of course I got to.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Got to.
They gonna fag off if you don't.
If you ain't supplying the drugs
they gonna go get it from somebody else.
- [Mark] And how old are you?
- Right now, I'm 30?
- [Mark] You're 30?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you've been doing this
since you were, half your life.
- Since I, yup.
- [Mark] Have you done prison time?
- Yeah.I did four years in prison.
- [Mark] What for?
- Pimping and pandering.
They dropped pimping and pandering down
to human trafficking, which carries life.
So my original term was 30 to life.
So I had to get lawyers and spend all,
you know, spend all my money on lawyers
and can't get pimping and pandering,
now get human trafficking.
First they was saying, they got me
on camera at the Bellagio in Las Vegas
they got a female giving
me $2,700 at the Bellagio.
So I'm pimping.
So in Vegas, the rules and regulations
are they don't hit you with pimping
and pandering because you
going to get right out.
So they hit you with human trafficking.
So you know what I'm saying?
Long story short.
You know what I'm saying?
The bitch kept coming
like, that's family and all of that.
He moved from California to Vegas.
So he needed moving money and
all of that, we is people.
So I was able to beat that.
But I got caught with crystal meth.
When they raided through
apartments looking
for me, I got caught with crystal meth,
as well as, I got into an
altercation with a Las Vegas crip.
You know what I'm saying?
It was my birthday
We was going up.
We was doing crystal meth.
And you know what I'm saying?
It was just crazy.
You know what I'm saying?
He took me for granted.
Man, that shit got ugly.
I grabbed the kitchen knife.
We was already high on crystal meth.
So it's like, you know,
ain't nobody thinking.
You know what I'm saying?
So, yeah, man.
I ended up doing the worst.
By the grace of God, I didn't kill him.
You know what I'm saying?
But he ended up telling on me.
So the police came and
raided the apartments
and they was...
I was just fucked over
30 life. You feel me?
Pimping and pandering, human trafficking,
battery with the use of a deadly weapon
and substantial bodily harm
and possession of sales crystal meth.
So with all of that, I
spent all the money I had
and all the money my family had
to get everything dropped down.
And for me to just do a possession.
They even dropped my possession
of sales to possession.
You feel me?
Because I told them I was
using all of this man.
So I damn near never came home.
So I did 48 months though.
You feel me?
- [Mark] Do you have kids of your own?
- No, I don't got no kids yet.
But see, I only make
bitches walk the blade
when they in trouble.
Ain't no money walking the blade.
You feel me?
That's just for a new whore bitch
that wants some attention.
Ain't nobody walking the blades no more.
You feel me?
A real pimp don't got
no whores on a blade.
Every bitch on a blade
is on dope, they weird.
You know what I'm saying?
The best thing to do is post ads.
You feel me?
So if you got like all my whore bitches
they got tricks lined
up that's gonna call.
In calls, out calls.
That's, what's popping. You feel me?
A in call is somebody
who gonna pull up on you.
Out call is somebody who
wants you to pull up on them.
You feel me?
So that's really where the money at.
'Cause when you're
doing, when you post ads,
now and it's a $200 a condo.
You feel me?
And when you got walking the blade
they jump in the car popping $40 dates.
You feel me?
That's disgusting, that's nasty.
Now you bringing back infections
and that's STD's in your
camp and all of that shit.
Now you not a responsible pimp.
You feel me?
So it's, it's levels to this shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's real levels to this shit.
You can be a reckless
ass pimp or you can be
a classy pimp that got respect
for yourself, as well as your whores.
And you can keep everybody clean.
So everybody can be fucking,
'cause I know I'm fucking.
I don't want no whore around me
that I ain't fucking.
That's weird. That's weird.
You feel me?
So if a bitch don't bring...
My bitches noun days.
It's rare for my bitch not to bust a day.
Cause I post ads. You feel me?
I get a room.
We post ads, the phone ringing all night.
So I make bitch walk a
blade if I'm mad at her.
Make her walk the blade, no
shoes on if I'm mad at her.
You feel me?
Like type shit.You know what I'm saying?
'Cause bitches like to do shit
and do little funny shit because
this bitch made more than her this night.
So she got a grudge and a vendetta on her.
So this week she was lazy as fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
And the only reason why she was lazy,
because she knows she
can't out-beat this bitch.
So it's just excuses.
So that's the type of
shit a pimp dealing with.
Like, bitch I see with my
own eyes, you're not tired.
You're not, that's not the case.
You know, you can't beat her.
You know what I'm saying?
So my bitches posts ads.
So I don't really have
to worry about them.
You feel me?
'Cause bitch if I pay $160 for a room,
bitch you better, somebody
better make it back.
- You feel me? (laughing)
Somebody better make it back.
- [Mark] What is the relationship you have
with women that are working for you?
I mean, do you use
intimidation and force to,
- Yeah. Sometimes you gotta
gorilla pimp. You feel me?
Sometimes you gotta put your hands
on a bitch and let a bitch know
that you ain't gonna play with her.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause we all out here taking
penitentiary chances for this shit.
So, a bitch, you not finna play.
You feel me?
You'd be a fool to play games
and you know what I'm saying.
Be sitting in jail.
So if that's what we going to do
and that's the role that's like
more than a 50% chance of the role,
then, yeah, bitch don't play.
You feel me?
You gonna have to put
your hands on a bitch.
The best things to do is
have you a white bitch.
You feel me?
If you have your white
bitch or Asian bitch she...
A bitch that's not black.
If you have you a bitch not black,
I promise you, you ain't going to have
to put your hands on her.
and she ain't going to bring
you a little bit more money.
You know what I'm saying?
When you dealing with black
bitches, African-Americans.
You know what I'm saying.
You gonna have to put your
hands on them, intimidate them.
And that's just because
where we come from.
You feel me?
It's like due to the circumstances
and situations that I'm pimping you home.
I know you're a real bitch
and you I'm a real nigga,
so shit a black man ain't gonna beat.
Some shit a black man
can't tell no black bitch.
You feel me?
You could tell a white bitch like,
look, go walk the blade with no shoes on.
Bitch you fucked up.
You feel me?
Give me your shoes, go stay down.
You can't, you can do
that with a black bitch
but you gonna have to put
your hands on her first.
You feel me? Because yeah, it's crazy.
You feel me?
- [Mark] What's the most
violent you've ever had
to get with one of your girls.
- I used to be, it was me
and two of my partners.
You feel me?
Man we had a little thing going on, man.
Renegade K.
You feel me?
So any bitch that was on our blades,
renegade, and didn't
have no worker, no pimp.
We used to do some little shit to 'em.
You feel me?
I don't want to say too much
and incriminate myself but yeah.
They used to... Long story short.
- [Mark] I don't wanna get you in trouble.
- Long story short, we
was gorilla pimping, man.
You feel me?
A bitch would come up missing.
You know what I'm saying?
For a couple of days, a couple of weeks
whatever you want to call it,
and she going to come back correct.
You know what I'm saying?
We was dealing with dog kennels,
we was dealing with cat food.
We had a whole bunch of
ways to get a bitch right?
You feel me?
You can't walk our blades
and you a renegade.
You have to be paying somebody bitch.
You can't be out here selling pussy
and you ain't paying nobody.
You know what I'm saying?
You can easily come up missing forever.
Like this shit real.
So like burning bitches
with cigarette butts.
Putting cigarettes out on
bitches, all type of shit, man.
Pouring bleach on bitches.
Making bitches bathe in bleach bath water.
Putting bitches in the shower
closing the door on them,
turning the hot water
and making them call you daddy.
While the want a hot water on.
You feel me?
And telling her, you know what I'm saying.
Like hey man, from now on I'm daddy
that's what you call me.
You know what I'm saying?
While the hot water running on her
and she screaming and all that shit.
You feel me?
So you gotta break their spirit.
Once they spirit is broke,
then you capable of
doing whatever with her.
You know what I'm saying?
That's real gorilla pimping.
But it's levels to this shit.
You feel me?
That's beginner shit.
After a while when you make
a name for yourself and all that
you ain't got to do that shit no more.
But this shit real man,
I did done some shit
to some bitches, man for sure.